[Music]
hi everyone it's joanna here this eight
minutes morning workout will help you to
burn fat lose weight building muscles
and make you look good this workout was
created by personal trainer and
best-selling author jorge cruz and he
has helped over 3 million people with
this workout so if you want to lose
weight and you don't have the time for
it do this this workout is based on the
foundation of strength training i've
always emphasized the importance of
strength training and that it should be
part of your workout every one pound of
lean muscles you build in your body will
help you to burn an additional 30
calories at rest therefore the more lean
muscles you have the more calories your
body will be burning at rest which will
prompt weight loss in order for this
workout to work all i'm asking you to do
is to get up 10 minutes earlier in the
morning and do the workout it will
kickstart your metabolic rate you will
start burning fat it will give you the
energy you need and it will make you
feel good throughout the day there will
only be two exercises in a day do one
set of 12 repetition from exercise a
then immediately one set of 12
repetitions from exercise b
repeat the entire cycle three more times
without resting and then you are done so
let me show you the workouts
start your workout with a brief warm-up
by jogging on the spot for one minute or
jumping jacks
on monday the muscles we want to be
focusing on are our chest and our back
muscles for our chest let's do dumbbell
press lie on the mat on your back with
your knees bent and your feet flat on
the floor holding one dumbbell in each
hand bring your elbows in line with your
shoulders and make sure that your
dumbbells are in line with your chest
exhale as you slowly extend your arms
and press the dumbbells towards the
ceiling keep your elbows loose hold for
one second inhale as you return to the
starting point and repeat
as for your back the workout is dumbbell
row you can choose to sit on a chair
hold one dumbbell in each hand lean
slightly forward and keep your chest
open extend your arms straight down
exhale as you slowly bring your elbows
towards the ceiling and squeeze your
back muscles extend your arms right down
and repeat
alternatively you can choose to stand
and roll i prefer standing as you will
need to tighten your abs in order to
keep your back straight and your chest
open throughout the workout
on tuesdays we want to be working on our
shoulders and abs for shoulders the
workout is lateral raise stand with your
feet shoulder width apart keep your back
straight tighten your core
hold one dumbbell in each hand exhale as
you slowly lift the dumbbells just
slightly above your shoulders with your
palms facing the floor release slowly
and repeat the move
for abdominals we want to be working on
crunches lie on your back with your
knees bent cross your arms and just
place them between your chin and your
collarbone
as you exhale
slowly crunch up to a 45 degrees angle
inhale and lower yourself back down and
repeat the move
on wednesdays we want to be working on
our arms triceps and biceps
for triceps the workout is lying
kickback or head crunches
lie on your back with a dumbbell in each
hand
keep your arms straight but keep your
elbows loose during the workout the only
part that should be moving are your
forearms bend your elbows and lower the
dumbbells down close to your head exhale
and straighten your arms back up by
squeezing your triceps and repeat the
moves
[Music]
as for your biceps we want to be doing
bicep curls stand shoulder width apart
hold a dumbbell in each hand with your
palms facing up
exhale as you curl both arms up bringing
your palms towards your biceps keep your
elbows close to your sides throughout
the workout focus on moving only from
your elbow joints and not from your
shoulders inhale as you lower your arms
back down and repeat
and on thursdays we want to be working
on our thighs hamstrings and quads for
hamstrings the workout is leg lift you
will need a chair for this or a higher
platform
lie on your back and place your heels on
the chair exhale as you lift your bum
and your upper thighs off the floor and
squeeze the back part of your thighs
which are your hamstrings hold for one
second inhale as you lower your butt
down and repeat the move
as for your quads let's do my favorite
workout squats stand with your feet
slightly wider than shoulder width apart
keeping your back straight and chest
open throughout the workout lower your
body down into a squat position and do
not let your knees extend past your toes
push up with your heels and repeat the
move you should be feeling on your
thighs and your butt
[Music]
on fridays let's work on our calves and
butt
so let's start with calf raises stance
shoulder width apart and you can choose
to hold a dumbbell in each hand
keep your chest and your shoulders open
and your abs tight exhale as you lift
your heels off the floor and rise onto
your toes hold for one second
inhale as you slowly lower yourself back
down alternatively you can choose to do
this on a higher platform which will
give you a higher intensity as well
now let's move on to kickbacks for your
butt
kneel on all fours with your knees hip
width apart your hands slightly wider
than your shoulders and your fingers
pointing forward bring your right leg
into a 90 degree angle exhale as you
slowly push your foot towards the
ceiling
bring it back to a 90 degrees position
and repeat
so do 12 repetitions on one side and 12
repetitions on the other side
[Music]
and on saturdays the muscles we want to
focus on are our inner thighs and outer
thighs
let's start with inner thigh leg raise
lie on your left side with your left
elbow and forearm supporting your upper
body bend your right knee and keep your
right foot on the floor for extra
balance keep your left leg straight
exhale as you lift your left foot as
high as you can hold for one second feel
and squeeze your inner thighs
inhale and lower it back down for a more
advanced version you can choose to place
your right foot on your left leg do one
set on your left leg and then switch
side and do another 12 repetitions on
your right side
as for your outer thigh let's do the
peeing dog movement
kneel on all fours with your knees hip
width apart your hands slightly wider
than your shoulders and your fingers
pointing forward keep your back straight
and tighten your core throughout the
workout keep your leg bent at a 90
degree angles exhale as you raise your
leg out to the side hold for one second
and squeeze your outer thigh inhale as
you lower your leg back down to the
starting point and repeat
same thing do 12 reps for one side and
switch sides and your out with a quick
total body stretches and you are done
if you do not have dumbbells you can
always be creative and use household
items make two weights one heavier
weights and one lighter weights with the
heavier weights use two big milk butter
and you can fill them up with water or
fill them up with stones to make them
even heavier for the lighter weights
use
two small bottles same thing use water
to fill them up or to increase your
weight use stones
this workout is exclusively for weight
loss and not for fitness gain in terms
of cardio therefore i would encourage
you to spend at least two to three times
weekly to do your regular cardio or to
do some cardio exercises according to my
videos according to jorge cruz if you
were to do this workout and to eat clean
and healthy you will be looking at
losing an average of 2 pounds per week
so spend eight minutes in the morning do
this workout for the next four weeks and
see the results
for new fitness food and motivational
videos please like share and subscribe
to my youtube channel and website
do follow me on facebook instagram and
twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
[Music]
you